c'est le récit d'un périple d'un voyage
à travers l'hexagone
le romancier et journaliste françois
guillaume lorrain a cherché 26 lieux qui
ont marqué l'histoire de france
je travaille en fait sur la sur la
mémoire des lieux ça y est en fait sur
les traces que laissent l'événement
l'histoire quand elles arrivent dans ces
lieux depuis donc le moment venu
l'événement jusqu'à aujourd'hui il y
avait des incontournables c'est à dire
des mythes pour nous dans notre
imaginaire comme marignan comme comme
bouvines ce soit des batailles comme
valmy com après il y avait des petits
plaisirs que je voulais m'offrir je
voulais refaire la fuite du roi louis
saez havane
je vais savoir exactement comment ça
s'était passé ce drame pourquoi il était
arrêté qu'est ce qui s'était passé dans
cette rue des recherches faites au fil
de ses articles pour l'hebdomadaire le
point
ces lieux qui ont fait la france or en
2015 l'auteur le présenté jeudi dernier
à la clé des champs de plaisir ce sont
des conférences sur des sujets divers et
variés qui peuvent se rapproche si vous
voulez ses choix des sujets historiques
soient des sujets pure littérature pure
nous recevons des écrivains qui nous
parle de tout leur cursus soit
scientifique soit c'est très très
variable la prochaine conférence se
tiendra le jeudi 24 novembre
il y sera question de philosophie